hey folks time for another movie
retrospective yeah what was name of this
one again session 9 session 9 goal I
don't remember this one well you weren't
really paying attention we were watching
so many movies on that day I think you
know I mean I kind of lose track of
which ones we're gonna review you know I
mean if it's a new movie yeah sometimes
I'll forget yes did you start talking
about it I'll remember ballroom this is
not this is our retrospective so this is
not a new movie this is from 2001 okay
yeah
yeah so this is like yeah this one is it
comes up a lot I'm like kind of
underrated horror lists and stuff like
that because it did have kind of like a
brief theatrical run back in 2001 but it
didn't really do very well I think it
made like less than half a million
dollars but in the years since it's
steadily built up like kind of a cult
following because it's actually a really
really good movie and it's really really
creepy
I decided been wanting to do it for a
while but then I was excited because
shudder just added it the other day now
I should tell you guys right now that
it's really hard to talk about this
movie without spoiling it so I'm gonna
spoil it so if you haven't seen it then
don't watch this come back and watch it
later to do the same style
yeah because I'm gonna be going into
like because there's like a lot of
there's a whole like fan Theory wiki
about this movie and stuff like that
because it's one of those ones it's been
compared to the shining in the sense
that it's like a psychological horror
but it's possible that there could be
supernatural elements as well but it
leaves it ambiguous as to like which it
is and there's actually like a couple of
there's a couple of different ways you
could read it you know what I mean yeah
I remember this one now
yes so there you go so this was actually
directed by Brad Anderson this was his
first horror movie prior to this he had
done two rom-coms of all things but I
guess he had been wanting to do a horror
movie and he got permission to film in
the abandoned and very famous Danvers
State Hospital in Massachusetts which is
an abandoned
an asylum so he specifically wrote this
script to take advantage of that
location and the interesting thing about
this movie is that there is almost no
set dressing it's like they brought a
couple of props but that's it
the rest of the stuff that you see in
the movie was exactly the way that they
found it they obviously were only
allowed to film in like four or five
rooms because most of it was like very
dangerous so you know they only got
permission to film in like a small area
of the hospital which is very large but
but it's just it's cool the way they
just he saw that location they said you
can film there in this like limited
place and then he's like okay well I'm
gonna write a script around it which I
think it's like a really good idea I
don't think a lot of people like take
advantage of that kind of [ __ ] that's
kind of what they do with escape in New
York yeah it's just you know you have
burned-out section of city and they're
like we're gonna make a movie here yeah
and like I said and writing the story
around it like to take advantage of that
particular location and I think this
movie probably this is probably one of
the best examples of a movie where the
location is almost like a character in
its own right you know what I mean
because if and they even like say this
in the movie but Danvers State Hospital
one it's super creepy inside you know
it's abandoned there's graffiti and
everything like that they like I said
they didn't put any of that there that
was the way it was when they got there
and it's like it's huge and it shaped
like and the one guy says this to them
at the beginning that's shaped like a
bat like the middle part is like the bat
body and then it kind of like it's two
wings like one wing was for the men and
one wing was for the women and it kind
of looked comes out like crooked bat
wings and they do like some kind of like
crane shots and stuff like that of the
above so you can see like what the
layout of it is so the plot behind this
movie is that I mean it's very simple
it's just basically there's a bunch of
guys they are a and asbestos removal
team and apparently you know the city is
wanting to either I don't know if they
were gonna like tear down Danvers or if
they're gonna like
it fun fact that actually some of it has
been converted to apartments nowadays
some of it was torn down but they did
actually convert some of the rest of it
so they won all the asbestos removed so
this kind of like one-man business
that's doing it he's only got it's it's
one guy and he's got like you know
rotating crew of like three or four guys
and he has a new baby and he really
needs this job because I guess he hasn't
been getting a lot of jobs like lately
and so he drastically like underbids
you know whoever else had like bid on
the job like he was like begging the
guys like look I really need the money
and [ __ ] like that and he perhaps
unwisely tells the guy that even though
his crew says oh well it's gonna take
like three weeks at least to clear all
the asbestos out of here he tells the
guy it's gonna be done in a week just to
like Jay get the cops to get the
contract because he really really needs
it and they said okay well if you get it
done in a week then you each get like a
ten thousand dollar bonus so they're
super hyped about that so it's kind of
cool because you don't see a lot of you
don't see a lot of horror movies that I
guess are like just working-class guys
you know what I mean that are just like
doing a job and then like all the [ __ ]
kind of happens but the interesting
thing about it is that so they go in
there and they kind of start getting to
work and everything but there's there's
a little bit of you know the characters
there's some kind of conflict there with
like you know the one guy who is you
know the main guy he's played by a
Scottish actor actually I think the
penis the actor's name is Peter Mullan
and I had actually recognized him with a
lot of like Ken Loach movies and stuff
like that so I thought it was kind of
cool that he was in this one the cast in
this is really really good David Caruso
was in it as well he's kind of the other
main character playing Phil and those
two guys have been working together a
long time like the one guy gets his
nephew it's like there's this one guy
named Hank who's kind of like a [ __ ]
around who was actually stolen Phil's
girlfriend and so there's like some
conflict there and he's also kind of
like a gambling addict and all
other kind of [ __ ] so each of them kind
of bring their own [ __ ] to the table but
they come in and they're ready to get to
work and you know get all this bonus and
everything like that but interestingly
one of the team who I believes name is
Mike he gets kind of sidetracked when he
finds these old tapes of an old session
of a patient that used to be at the
hospital named Mary Hobbs and apparently
she has what they now call dissociative
identity disorder they spell it multiple
personality disorder and there are all
these tapes of her like talking to the
doctor like in her various personality
guises and as the movie goes on and they
talk to all her different personalities
you know they start to close in on what
exactly happened it was like something
that happened when she was a kid and she
doesn't want to face it and [ __ ] like
that and all her kind of all her
personalities are kind of like trying to
protect her from this knowledge of like
what she did when she was a kid and
everything but the interesting thing
about it is that as the guy is listening
to these tapes and you know the the
story of what happened with the old
patient is getting more and more
intricate you're finding more and more
details about it it almost seems to like
reflect what's going on with the guys
that are working in the insane asylum
you know what I mean so it's kind of
like this thing where you know they're
all working with each other they're you
know they're working really hard because
they're trying to get this [ __ ] done but
like I said there's some interpersonal
[ __ ] between them so there's like a lot
of stress and [ __ ] like that so you know
tempers are getting flit are getting
frayed and various things of that nature
so it almost seems like the one thing is
reflecting on the other thing now it's
like I said it's kind of a slow burn it
reminds me a little bit in it other
people have compared it to the shining
where it's just kind of like these guys
it's very isolated and they're it's
possible that there's some supernatural
[ __ ] going on now as I said I'm gonna
spoil this because if I don't you can't
really talk about it what what you find
out as the story goes on because like
this it's a very slow burn
you get like Hank who you know he comes
back - he's goat he's farting around
down in the you know basement or
whatever one of the rooms so they're
supposed to be removing some asbestos
and he finds like a hole in the wall and
all these coins like start falling out
of it like it's almost kind of like a
you know like a what do you call it a
[ __ ] thing at the casino the Machine
one of the [ __ ] slot machines I could
not remember the name of that thing so
it's almost kind of like that where all
these like old silver coins are falling
out and he's like super jazzed and he's
like oh he's gonna like this this is my
exit strategy these are like gonna be
they're worth all this money and then
they kind of pulled back and you see
that they're come falling out of the
crematorium like he falls on this [ __ ]
oh they're crematorium and so he he also
finds one of those big long things where
they you know where they used to give
people you know they'd stick in your
eyeball and yeah he finds one of that so
so you know because he finds that in
there you know that that's probably good
enough happening to him and it does yeah
but yeah they kind of go into that
lobotomy thing early on so because
there's this like the whole conversation
between the lobotomies they used to give
there and I guess there was they said
that it closed the insane asylum closed
because of like public funding got cut
but also because there was like some
kind of like satanic panic kind of
scandal which I thought was a nice touch
so yeah so he finds that all this other
stuff so he like sneaks back in the
middle of the night so he can get all
these coins and like get the [ __ ] out of
Dodge so the so he doesn't have to share
it with the other guys and while he's
there he gets attacked by an unseen
individual so like I said it kind of
goes on like this where you're not
really sure if it's a person like if
it's like one of the guys or if it's
like a ghost or what it is exactly
because like I said you keep hearing
these creepy tapes and and the main guy
Gordon who's played by Peter Mullan he's
like keeps hearing a disembodied voice
like hello Gordon and stuff like that
and then he's like who the [ __ ] is that
you know so he keeps hearing things so
you kind of think maybe it's haunted
that's not really what's going on as it
turns out yeah the movie is a well made
movie but it requires you to pay close
attention to it it's a it's like a it's
like a mystery movie it has elements of
that yeah and like I said this is
definitely it can be seen as
supernatural but it's definitely a
psychological horror yeah you have to be
in the mood mood for it when I was
watching it I really wasn't in the mood
for kind of movie that you really had to
pay real close attention to but you know
if I was in that mood which sometimes I
am then I'll probably have enjoyed it a
lot more it wasn't really holding my
attention at the time like I said it
went in the mood for it yeah and a lot
of it when you're a lot of watching
movies has to do with the mood yeah you
know I mean like I've seen some movies I
hate them at the time but it's because
the mood I was in you go back to see it
later you know yeah it's pretty cool
yeah
mood has a lot to do with it it does
yeah because I've seen you know I've had
the same thing happen where I saw
something I was like well this seems
good but I don't really feel like
watching it right now because like you
know some nights I'm in the movie mood
for like oh let's watch a slasher movie
or like you know some nights I want to
watch an old one some nights I wanna
know what to watch a new one so you know
so anyway so like I said as Gordon who
seems to be like the main focus of this
whatever this is this malevolent force
what she think it is at the beginning
because he seems to be getting more and
more upset there are some you know his
his temper is getting very short he
seems to be like forgetting things and
he's getting like really absent-minded
and also you start to suspect that
something weird is going on like with
his family because they show like shots
of him sitting in this car like across
the street from his house and like his
wife and baby like go back inside the
how like his wife looks at him sadly is
that he's been like kicked out of the
house or something you know and he keeps
hearing things like screams and [ __ ]
like that and finally he confesses to
like one of the other guys that he
actually hit his wife and so and he
feels really bad about it
so you think well maybe this is what
this is this is why he's kind of like
unraveling you know not only that but
like I said the stress of trying to get
the job done and like this creepy
[ __ ] place and all this other stuff
but it turns out spoiler alert
that he has actually killed his wife and
baby and their dog yeah the day that he
found out that they got the contract
what ended up happening was that he went
home like with flowers and champagne and
everything like just he's like oh I got
a job we'll celebrate you know I got a
big job and I guess she like
accidentally she was cooking something
and she accidentally like spilled like
dumped boiling water on him like because
he still has like a like blistering on
his leg and [ __ ] and I guess he just
like flipped out and just like went to
town and just like killed the whole
family and so because he had been like
kind of getting mentally more and more
like [ __ ] [ __ ] up they kind of like
hinted that you know having the new baby
and everything like that like he's just
getting more more stressed out so his
entire family is dead but you don't
really know that until the end and then
you find out that he when Hank came back
to get the money out of the wall
Gordon stuck the lobotomy thing like in
his eyeball said that dudes still alive
because one of the other crew like they
think because Hank is gone and they
think oh well he must have just like you
know one he was always doing scratch-off
tickets they said maybe he's just one
one and just like took off because he
wasn't like super conscientious or
anything so they didn't really think
that much about it but then a day or two
later one of them sees him like just
standing up by the window very creepily
and he's just like kind of half dressed
and he just keeps saying what are you
doing here what are you doing here and
like so they can't figure out like what
the [ __ ] he's doing there and then like
when they go back he's gone so they
think he's imagining it and all this
other kind of [ __ ] but it turns out that
Gordon has been doing all of this the
whole time like he did that to Hank and
then he ends up killing all the other
guys but it's almost kind of like he's
dissociated so like I said there's
relationship between his mental
breakdown and the tapes
of this Mary Hobbs patient that that mic
has been listening to you like in the
basement now okay so you find out that
Mary Hobbs in the past she had this
malevolent personality named Simon and
he was the one that's been talking he's
like has this super creepy voice and
he's the one he was talking on the tape
but also Gordon heard him like you know
he heard him talking like in his head
and Simon apparently told her to kill
her brother and her parents which she
did when she was a little girl and you
know so then she her personality said
dissociated and she had like forgotten
about it so she was like in the hospital
trying to like sort through her feelings
about it and everything now there are
several theories about Simon because
some people think that Simon was not
actually one of Mary Hobbes's
personalities but was actually a demon
or was the personification of rage or
anger or something like that which is
why you know Mary Hobbs in the past had
this personality that made her kill her
family and then Gordon in the present
who had heard Simon's voice like in his
head and had also killed his family like
you hear him saying things like do it
Gordon and [ __ ] like that
so that's how a lot of people have
interpreted that maybe Simon is like a
demon and that he like possessed or
something like that then again there it
could be to that I kind of like the
interpretation where Gordon is like
because some people have thought all the
other guys like in the crew like on his
crew like he imagined them like those
are all his personalities or that maybe
Gordon is not a real person and that
he's one of Mary Hobbes's personalities
there's like a really lot and like I
said there's a whole like [ __ ] fan
theory ways it's not not to the extent
of the shining where there's like all
these crazy
these theories about it and everything
but there are a lot of different
interpretations of what Simon is exactly
like if he is an entity that is making
people do these things or if he's just
like a representation of everyone's
capacity for evil you know what I'm
saying
yeah because there's a couple lines like
when Mike is listening to the tapes of
Mary Hobbs and she's talking to she's
talking in some of the other personality
voices like the doctor is asking like
where all these personalities live like
in her body and she has this one called
the princess and I think that one like
lives in her tongue because she talks a
lot and then you know she has another
one that lives in the eyes because they
see everything and so at the end when he
asks Simon like where does Simon live
like in Mary Hobbes's body simon says I
live in the wheat and the wounded
meaning that he might not be a thing
like an entity he might be just
everyone's capacity for evil you know
what I mean
so but like I said there have been like
a ton of different [ __ ]
interpretations of this I kind of like
that better I don't know if I like the
idea that Simon is like a demon that
just latched on to Gordon
I like the idea more that they're more
like parallel stories and that maybe he
just hears Simon's voice because that's
just the voice that is compelling people
to do things like that like when they
start to crack or whatever but um but
yeah it's like it's it makes me sad
because I feel like this movie it's just
really really good and it's just it's
really creepy and it's just kind of like
it's you know it's a slow burn like I
said it's a psychological or if you like
The Shining I would think that you would
probably you probably dig it because
it's kind of a similar thing where you
know this is just a really creepy place
and like I said and in this case it's a
real place you know and it's just these
guys that are kind of slowly losing
their sanity a little bit you know like
in their interactions with each other
and then
they you know the kind of the past
reflecting on the present and everything
like that but it really kind of makes me
sad the way it when it first came out in
2001 it kind of came and went and then
for years it seemed like one of those
ones just kind of fell through the
cracks and everyone sort of forgot about
it and I feel like now if you watch
because I do like a lot of I watch a lot
of horror channels and there's like a
lot of lists of like you know best
underrated horror and the usually this
is on there and I think even nowadays
like some horror channels have it like
listed as in their top ten of you know
horror movies at the 2000s which I would
definitely agree with like you said I
mean you really have to be in the kind
of mood to watch it because it's not
like monsters it's nothing like that
there's some gore in it like some bloody
murders and stuff like that but it
doesn't really happen till the end most
of the first part of it is just like a
psychological horror it's just like
mystery you're just kind of like
watching these guys interact with each
other and then there's like a kind of
like just weirder and where does kind of
ramps up like a little weird yeah I was
under the impression that the movie
probably wouldn't play real well before
a theater but that's true our live
audience this is more like something
that you'd watch at home and you're a
you're a horror movie freak yeah that
occur in the mystery type person and you
pick through it over and over again try
to figure it out it's like one of those
kind of movies yeah it's really just
something you go in there take a date
with popcorn and [ __ ] dude yeah it's not
that it's not really like that
that's usually what does well at the box
office that's true it's just like more
like something that would do well on you
know blu-ray because this is definitely
one that you need to kind of digest and
then you need to see it a couple more
times because there's a lot of [ __ ] I've
seen some people that saw it like once
and they liked it but they didn't really
get it like they were like what exactly
is like going on like did he really do
this and who was Simon and what's all
this but I definitely do feel like one
there's a lot of interpretations at - I
don't think any of them are necessarily
correct
but it's definitely one that you really
need to re-watch now what I've heard is
that apparently it has an alternate
ending that some people like better and
there was like a lot of deleted scenes
and from everything I've heard like I
haven't seen them but a lot of people
thought that they probably should have
left them in there because apparently
they cut out an entire character who was
like she was a homeless woman and
apparently she had been a patient there
now because there was a like a line of
dialogue near the beginning of the movie
where they said you know we had to clear
this place out you know the kids come in
here and drink and [ __ ] like that and
homeless people and or ex-patients that
like come back here and they were like
making a joke about like why the [ __ ]
would they want to come back to like a
mental asylum or anything and he's like
yeah I know right and like all that kind
of stuff but apparently there was a
whole character who had been a patient
there and she kept coming back and I
guess I think in the alternate ending
she ended up being the killer I'm not
really sure how that whole thing worked
out because her whole entire character
was removed but I think what ended up
happening was that test audiences they
didn't like her character because they
thought that she was supposed to be Mary
Hobbs you know the original patient and
I guess she wasn't so people were like
confused about was like well if it's not
Mary Hobson what is she doing in the
movie so they took her whole [ __ ] out
yeah you know I mean so that might so if
you have the blu-ray it apparently has
like all these deleted scenes that are
alternate ending on it that like I said
I've seen some people actually liked it
better but it kind of seems to put like
a whole new spin on the plot and like a
whole new kind of reminds me of
Prometheus yeah aliens fans hate you
know they hated Prometheus when it came
out it kind of bombed at the theater and
yeah they griped about it you know they
just because it wasn't exactly what they
wanted but I love that movie I watch you
can watch it over and over again try to
pick it apart that an alien covenant
you know because it doesn't spell it out
and it's not what you expect and you
know so they're saying no it doesn't
make sense but if you watch it enough
times it does make sense just that it's
not it's not really meeting up with your
expectations so you know to mean that
like ticular movie because they wanted
to go a certain way and that's not the
way that movie is going well like I said
I always thought that was really lame
granted to if you you know and I said
this probably in our Halloween show too
but it's like that's why I'm very
willing to just like I I don't like
having expectations of any kinds like
when I go watch it maybe like yeah
there's ones that I want to say like if
it's a horror movie I'll probably want
to go see it more than another kind of
movie for example but I try not to read
reviews it's like sometimes I see a
trailer but that's about as far as I'll
go
I don't like to look at the audience
ratings I don't like to look at anything
like that alright I don't even really
like to know what it's about
so much I just like to kind of like take
it as it is and see how I feel about it
like I said I don't really like to have
any expectations because then you know I
just feel like you're setting yourself
up for disappointment well that's what
happened with the audience that you know
audiences that paid go see Prometheus
tonight I mean they they approached that
movie with a whole bunch of baggage from
Alien and Predator
and then they assumed a lot of stuff
like they assumed that the crew of the
previous was the crew when they weren't
the crew yeah the crew was the damn
robot the robot yeah I mean the crew was
just damn test subjects you know yeah I
mean think about movies I mean I like a
movie that doesn't spell things out for
you right I like a movie that I'm like
man I need to see that [ __ ] again
because that was some messed up [ __ ] and
I probably like missed a bunch of stuff
which like I said that's why I like
session 9 that's why I like you know
David Lynch movies that's why I like
Mulholland Drive and stuff like that and
I can sit and talk about that all day
because there's so many different like
interpretations that you could take away
from it that it's just it just makes it
such a richer experience I mean I don't
you know sometimes I'll watch a movie
and it's like fun in the moment but it's
like then a couple days later you don't
remember
and it's like you know so I don't know
if I like movies like that but they're
just disposable I like a movie that you
can just like watch over and over and
you can find something new in it every
time which is probably why the shining
is on my favorite movies because every
time I watch that I noticed something
else or I have like a new take on it you
know what I mean
right and I feel like session 9 is a
little bit like that like I said if you
can there's a whole bunch of different
there's a supernatural way you can take
it there's like a psychological way you
can take it you can take it as like a
parallel type of thing you show the
demonic thing maybe it's possession
maybe it's not maybe it's this that and
the other thing so that I think to me
that is like that's really the hallmark
of a good movie
when later on you know years after this
movie came out 18 years after this movie
came out talking about it they're still
talking about it and they're talking
about all these different theories and
new people are watching and it's been
like well do you think this that and the
other thing do you really think all
those other people existed were they
really
Gordon's other personalities were they
all like aspects of his personality just
like Mary Hobbs had all those different
personalities and [ __ ] like that so it's
just like really cool that the movie
that was made for this little money you
know really kind of took off amid you
know horror freaks and like they just
still talk about it nowadays and I've
seen some people say that like this
movie was like one of the creepiest
things that they'd ever seen because
that one even if the movie hadn't been
as good as it is that [ __ ] asylum is
real and it's creepy as [ __ ] like all
the shots of it are really creepy and
everything like that but then you have
all you have such a great cast like you
know they work really well together you
have all this creepy [ __ ] tapes like
that Simon voice which is like super
weird and then like you have this whole
psychological crap going on and it's
like really really creepy and it's just
like it's such a great movie and it's
just like I'm really glad that it seems
to have gotten a little bit better known
nowadays because I feel like I didn't
even see it until many years after it
came out just because
some-something's get appreciated as time
goes along yeah a lot of things are not
appreciated at the time they came out I
mean [ __ ] look at something like you
know the thing we use that for an
example all the time that was pretty
critically
yeah people didn't like the thing when
it came out and yeah audiences didn't
like it either like when it first came
out my dad liked it a few other people
liked it like hardcore fans liked it you
know but the general audience they hated
to think that's crazy to me
yeah I mean because that is clearly
remember when it was in thewhat have the
most awesome movie planner I remember
one of us in theater you know I'd be I'd
tell people oh man you seen the thing or
like no I would say oh no they would
they weren't interested they weren't to
see you to you though people are talking
about grownups yeah you know but I was
10
yeah of course I haven't really had a
desire to see it again since then but
you know oh and fun fact I meant to
mention this but the in session nine you
know Gordon liked killing his wife and
kid and everything like that because of
the boiling water and everything
apparently Brad Anderson who weren't
directed this he got the idea from a
real-life murder that happened in Boston
in the mid-1990s and this was the
Richard Rosenthal case and apparently
the guy comes home from work or wherever
his wife accidentally burt's his dinner
yeah so she killed so he killed her cut
her heart out and her lungs and put them
on a stake in his backyard
I remember that although it wasn't just
because of the burning that you know I
remember that that's a little excessive
details but if there was more to it than
that
well there always is yeah but and one of
the factors being that he was a [ __ ]
nut well clearly yeah because you know
people burn food all the time you all
need to settle down nobody deserves
getting their [ __ ] heart and plugs
cut out put on a steak just for burning
your [ __ ] mac and cheese or whatever
the hell
but yeah so seriously if you haven't
seen session I know just spoiled it
everything like that but tell me what
you're like theories about it are I tend
to think he's probably like Simon's
probably not a demon but if you want to
think that that's perfectly legit it's
you know there's there's evidence to
support that theory as well but if you
want to watch it I'm sure you can run
out Amazon Prime but shudder just added
it well probably like a week or two ago
which was the reason that I pushed it up
in the in the list of movies that we're
going to review because I've been
wanting to do this one for a while so
you should definitely check it out
because it's really really good